junge leute heute mal ein bisschen
anders mega spontan wären wir nur 14
würde mich super freuen wenn ihr euch
das video kurz anschaut
ich versuche es auch wirklich kurz zu
halten ich habe jetzt gerade schon ohne
rücksprache gehalten ich sag mal mit
meinem management in anführungszeichen
und auch mit anderen leuten die mir den
rat gegeben haben wie ich jetzt am
besten weiter fortfahren soll
ich bin gerade praktisch aus hamburg
wieder gekommen
ich war jetzt drei tage halt nicht in
köln und bin jetzt wieder gekommen war
auch echt müde und bin halt vom
flughafen ihren teil mit der bahn hier
hingefahren und bin dann aus der bahn
irgendwann ausgestiegen
ich mache das ganze als uncut weil es
einfach schnellstmöglich online gehen
soll weil ich mir immer noch eine
geringe chance ausmalen dass
wiederzubekommen
wenn aus der bahn ausgestiegen und habe
dann gemerkt ja mein rucksack ist weg
also meinen rucksack in dem ich alles
drin hatte da gehe ich gleich kurz ein
bisschen genauer drauf ein und ich
dachte heute farc alter habe die bahn
wegfahren sehen
und dann habe ich mich so zurück
erinnert er hast du diesen rucksack weil
ich habe eine dicke jacke an sondern
north face jakl ich hatte den rucksack
die ganze zeit darauf und dachte mir so
hast du den rucksack jetzt wirklich in
dieser bahn liegen lassen
oder war das vom vorjahr weil ich bin
zweimal umgestiegen noch vom kölner
flughafen bis hierhin zu mir nach hause
und bin mir allerdings ziemlich sicher
dass es dass ich den in der in dieser
bahn vergessen habe also in den kölner
kvb waren das in diese stadtbahn hier
diese die unter ihre sparen darüber hier
schon alle stadtbezirke und vielleicht
für die was mit anfangen können ich
nehme weil die einst nach weiden west
und steigt dann circa sieben stationen
vorher aus ich will jetzt nicht genau
was sagen weil das ich weiß nicht ob das
so schlau ist und auf jeden fall habe
ich mich dann zurück erinnert und hatte
auch eine begegnung am bahnhof ich hatte
alten musik in den ohren wo ich halt so
ein leichtes zucken irgendwie hier
gemerkt habe aber das irgendwie gar
nicht um total ignoriert also wenn ich
total packard hat mir den auch einer vom
rücken genommen ich bei ich weiß es
einfach nicht
ich hoffe aber dass ist dass sich dass
er vielleicht irgendwo liegt aber
mittlerweile denke ich mir auch etwas
kann sein dass die dann irgendwann vom
rücken genommen hat weil weiß nicht da
war ich da ich hab halt da sowas so
irgendwie etwas gespürt hat sich jetzt
auch ein bisschen druck auf jeden fall
kommen jetzt zu der schlimme sache ist
halt erstmal denkt man sich so okay ist
und einen rucksack ist gar kein problem
das problem ist allerdings in diesem
rucksack war erst mal mein macbook drin
und auch eine kamera was jetzt auch gar
nicht mal so schlimm ist das schlimme
ist allerdings dass da auch mein
autoschlüssel drin war und im worst case
sag ich mal
wenn die personen gesehen haben wo ich
ausgestiegen bin deswegen mache ich das
jetzt gerade auch noch irgendwie
vielleicht ist es auch falsch jetzt dazu
einen schnellen im video zu drehen um zu
hoffen dass das vielleicht irgendwie
auftaucht aber es kann ja diese chance
besteht ja und in diesem buch sind
wirklich super viele sehr wichtige dinge
von mir auch festplatten und so und
jetzt ja das ist aber eigentlich der
grund warum ich dieses video mache weil
ich warum ich denn so schnell wie
möglich wieder haben wir wegen bei dem
autoschlüssel und wenn die halt gesehen
haben okay da ist er ausgestiegen krass
alter da ist ein autos halt drin ist ja
ein muster schlüssel und so weit von der
station weg wohne ich jetzt auch nicht
und gehen hier lang gesehen da guck mal
da und ich habe jetzt extra heute nach
nachbarn gefragt ob die mitfahrer im
auto parken können ich habe auch schon
alles mögliche versucht den eben wieder
zu bekommen
ich bin zurück ich habe die
polizeistationen hier angerufen weil es
halt so wichtig ist weil da halt mein
auto zu dünn ist und theoretisch einfach
einer mainaufwärts nehmen könnte also
ich stufe diese chance dass es so
passieren könnte gar nicht mal so gering
ein benz halt bei neben ihr saßen so
zwei sind pärchen werden so 30 oder so
und man kann den leuten einen kopf
gucken also das könnten müssten
eigentlich die einzigen gewesen sein die
den gesehen haben dann direkt also die
haben ihn
wie im fall gesehen wenn ich ihn da
liegen gelassen habe es kann natürlich
auch sein dass er mir entwendet wurde
vorher leute ich weiß es nicht
auf jeden fall wollte ich euch jetzt
vielleicht mal fotos ein werden von den
sachen die da drin sind und vielleicht
tauchen die ja irgendwo auf und ihr
könnt mir könnte es dann aber nicht
weiterleiten
weil dieses video allein schon 100
200.000 leute sehen oder so da
vielleicht auch dann dass er jetzt
wieder in köln wurden dass man irgendwie
eine gruppe schickt von freunden oder so
von euch das ist ja eine enorm große
reichweite und die chance ist wirklich
da das vielleicht wieder auftaucht und
genau also ich bin halt schon hier
komplett ich habe auch den fahrer in der
bahn ich war in der bahn und der ich war
schon wieder auf ausfindig gemacht hat
mit ihm gesprochen er ist mir die ganze
bahn durchgang und meinte hier ist
nichts ich bin die durchgegangen geht
jemand auch hier wenn ich nur einmal die
anschlusszüge erreicht habe schaue ich
mir die ganze bar an
und da war nichts drin also keinen
rucksack wurde gefunden
sorry dass ich sozusagen durch den wind
gerade und jetzt bleibe ich euch hier
mal kurz ich versuchen von einem foto
von meinem macbook zu finden
das ist dann so sieht es aus da ist halt
so
ja so ein sticker drauf dann war da noch
drin ladekabel zu einem sachen dann die
canon 600d nämlich die 6b dies erkennen
so eine kleine können die canon
powershot das ist aber alles wie gesagt
nur nebensächlich und halt mein auto
schlüssel denn wenn ich euch auch mal
hier ein und aus erfahrung hat der
fahrer hat gesagt ja wenn das jemand
gefunden hat hier das ist also nur sehr
wenige menschen nur leider so ehrlich
und sehen dann da ein computer drin
umgeben das ab also er meint ich soll
meine chance nicht zu sehr einschätzen
ich soll jetzt alles versuchen was ich
irgendwie machen kann
deswegen habe ich jetzt auch das hier in
betracht gezogen sonst würde ich das
niemals machen das so öffentlich zu
machen weil es mir einfach extrem
wichtig ist dass wieder zu bekommen und
natürlich wenn wir irgendwie dazu helfen
kann gibt es auch eine entsprechende
belohnung oder so dafür
ich hoffe nur dass es irgendwie möglich
ist und ich hoffe darauf eure
unterstützung dass ihr das vielleicht
teilt einfach hier vielleicht noch mal
ein foto von diesem von diesen sachen
oder
mein finger auf den link zum video ist
auch überhaupt keine werbung oder
sonstiges hier drauf es gibt mir einfach
nur um die sache und vor allem halt um
dieses auto was halt an den größten dort
natürlich hat heute nacht kann nichts
passieren
aber das ist natürlich auch keine
dauerlösung vor allem das ganz schwierig
zu erklären auf der kamera sind dann
auch noch fotos natürlich von mir oder
videos und auch mein kompletter name das
heißt theoretisch wenn es halt leute
sind die sich da richtig reinhängen kann
ja dann auch meine adresse irgendwie
ermitteln und das auto kriegt gerade
hier nicht weg weil ich keinen schlüssel
ab also jetzt gerade ist absolut gezeigt
das auto ja also ich drücke mir einfach
mal die daumen
und vielleicht habe ich ja diese kleine
chance die noch besteht das wieder zu
bekommen
ich hoffe es nachts gut vielleicht hört
hat davon morgen oder übermorgen oder so
noch was ich werde bestimmt noch mal ein
kleines fazit dazu auf instagram oder
vielleicht auf youtube osten
ich bin auch ein trottel ehrlich und ich
denken immer noch ich weiß nicht aber
mir geklaut wurde wirklich weil das kann
ja sein nachts vor allem dann manchmal
in hier bezirken wo man da ist am
bahnhof da laufen ja auch krasse
gestalten herum oder ob ich ihn neben
mir vergessen habe ich habe mir
eigentlich immer vor mir liegen
ich hab mir immer vor mir liegen und
nehmen dann eigentlich also ich hab noch
nie weil ich denke immer daran
eigentlich also ich wunder mich selber
für mich war auch sehr müde und so bin
ich halt immer noch
naja ansonsten war es das macht's gut
und schreibt mir super gerne wenn er
irgendwas bei instagram wie gesagt hier
vielleicht noch mal die fotos von den
sachen und denkt dran
ich werde mich revanchieren falls mir
irgendwann hinweis geben kann und die
sache wieder auftauchen
haut rein